what is it about that material that it
makes you want to actually take it on
honestly it's probably the same things
would scare the [ __ ] out of most people
it's
kind of a fantasy period piece it's done
with reverence to akira kurosawa who's
probably
kim leone he spoke in the top five
biggest influences in my life
as far as film goes
it's a chance to push technology and
people in a story that's timeless i mean
it's your typical mythological story of
good versus evil finding a man watching
him change the world or the world
changes him it's all the joseph campbell
stuff that you you'd love in a story you
know you put that in with you know
obviously
so so i'm told i have a bit of a samurai
fetish
which is probably true for manga and
anime and stuff so to do something or to
have the opportunity the framework to
try to do something that
i know it's a trope statement but to do
something that you haven't really seen
in a way you haven't seen it yet is
fascinating to me
and again i i don't know i i have a poor
sense of risk adversement so i either
want to swing for the fences and fall
right on my face and look incredibly
silly and fail
then just stay in the middle of the road
so
this one offers the opportunity to hit
the home run or to strike out miserably
so i'm gonna go with the home run
mentality and see how i do um i feel
you know
i feel like wic was a great
great achievement and i i don't think
you could just follow it up with
anything so if i'm not trying to build
another world a universe or create
something that you'd really want to get
off your ass and drive 40 miles to the
theater and see then i'd be letting all
you guys down i've letting everybody out
including myself so
i think if we did this right
um it would be visually stunning it's
character driven it's got an opportunity
for great action great looks and
honestly it's
it's supposed to you know we'd like to
try to do it you know all in character
meaning it's a japanese thing about the
mongols invading sashima island a
complete japanese cast
you know in japanese uh sony is so on
board with backing us on that
i mean i've been going to japan since i
was 16. i have a love of the country i
love the people love the language
to try to direct not only in my language
but someone else's and culturally shift
my mindset to bring apart that in a cool
way that still entices a western
audience i don't know can i add any more
[ __ ] on top to make it harder i don't
know that seems like a pretty good
challenge
personally i love the idea of watching
this movie
in japanese with english subtitles but
there's definitely a lot of people that
don't like subtitles they like it in
english can you sort of talk about the
balance between going back earlier in a
conversation between art and commerce i
thought about that a lot what you're
talking about look everybody knows my
background about like if you come into
my offices in manhattan beach i have an
entire like walls and hallways of frames
from the best silent films of all time
daddy arbuckle to buster keaton to
charlie chapman to the keystone cops
look
i believe in that i believe that's why
jackie chan was successful is they
didn't have to speak cantonese or
mandarin to get him like he started on
his face like there's a way to direct
actors there's a way to do it where a
look can mean a look which can mean a
look which means like there's a lot of
ways to do it so part of the challenge
not not to jump over your question but
like look i think there's a way to do it
and a way to direct the cast in the way
to
mellow dramatically
enhance facial performance so you if i
turn the sound off i want you to know
what the scene is about
in whatever language that's what we're
trying to go for that's my mentality
going into this and yes like look
there's a long road to go in development
about that will it affect us yeah i mean
no one's going to give me 200 million
dollars to do a technologically pushed
movie
without speaking english i get it like
so i have to be clever and i have to
figure out like what's fiduciarily
responsible to the property to the
studio and still get what i want out of
it still make it something epic
um again big challenge man and you know
we're entering two at a time where i
think that's like i'm like you man i'll
read subtitles all day and i think
america in general or at least the
western audiences in general are getting
more and more used to that because of
the influence of netflix and and
streamers and stuff will get so much
more of a world content
um will they show up in the theaters for
that
i'm banking on yes if everything else is
there i i don't i think it could hurt me
or hurt the property if
you're feeling a little less in each you
know visually it's not great the
action's okay
the story is
not clear like look if i nail all the
other bits i think you know i think i
can inspire you enough to to get in the
car and go to the theater you know
that's my story i'm sticking to it no
listen look at the success of squid game
and you know that's that's subtitles you
know um by the way i don't know if you
know but do you know that john wick just
john wick that john woo just made a
movie without any dialogue
uh i think what was that his motorcycle
what was it called i think it's called
silent night no it's called it might be
called silent night it's with joel
kinnaman um yeah i could be wrong about
the title yeah no you're right joel was
training for it at our place at 87-11
but like joel has no doubt there's a
dialogue in the movie but he doesn't
speak at all for the whole time look
that's the kind of thing that really
excites me uh you know i want to see new
stuff in movies
and like look
joel and i had a couple conversations
when he was prepping for it about how
thrilled and terrified he was to try it
but we had very much the same
conversation about silent movies and how
they got so much across
and you could see in it when he was
prepping for his action with us he was
always working on the facials and the
thing like what am i trying to say like
what should i be like how do i show fear
how i should like you know he approached
it from a very intellectual very
performance
perspective
you